long before this pandemic alarm bells
were ringing about the amount of
household debt Canadians are carrying
now the financial stress for many is
through the roof
some aren't earning at all many earning
less and millions are getting emergency
benefits from the government what
happens when all that ends david akin is
exploring that for us a 1986 honda
goldwing
a machine built for the open road my
husband and I love to ride motorbikes in
the summertime but just been something
that we've clicked with right from the
beginning when we first met but there
will not be any long trips this summer
no that's just not an affordable option
for us right now
in fact crystal Chalmers is fighting now
just to save her home we're really in a
rock and a hard place right now with the
pandemic crystal a house cleaner has not
been able to work since March
her husband's still working but on much
reduced hours
neither are eligible for benefits like
the Serb and while their bank has given
the Chalmers deferrals on the mortgage
payments they make on their mobile home
the owner of the lot has not given them
a break on the lot rent we're still
paying over $700 a month just for our
lot rents but now they're $2,500 in
arrears to the landlord and facing the
prospect of eviction bill collectors are
still calling even though you know
there's nothing we can do
lot rents right now even though we can
defer our mortgages and move all in
communities we can't defer our lot rents
and when you don't pay your rent you can
still lose your home to pay the bills
the chalmers have had to add to their
household debt the credit card balance
is higher they board a hundred here or a
hundred there from friends and family so
even if they get through all this they
are going to find themselves with more
debt we don't have a plan we're just
trying to survive right now millions of
Canadians are fighting the same
financial currents forced to take on
more debt to make it through the
pandemic it starts with a health crisis
that triggers an economic crisis that
quite likely is going to trigger an
insolvency crisis and how we handle each
one of these things depends on how we
handle the previous crisis and even
before the pandemic hit experts were
sounding the alarm about rising debt
levels fueled by low interest rates in a
relatively strong economy Canadians have
been borrowing more and more for
everything from new home appliances to
new cars to home renovations 20 years
ago Canadians had about a hundred and
six dollars worth of debt for
every $100 worth of disposable income
but over the last several years that
ratio of household debt to disposable
income has soared to 176 percent in
other words 176 dollars of debt for
every $100 of disposable income and that
was before the pandemic you're probably
going to see it soar to something like
230 percent and the reason is is that
the denominator income will will have
fallen because of the employment shock
that we're having during during the
pandemic and the lockdown so 230 dollars
of debt for every $100 in disposable
income I think we're probably gonna end
this crisis with even more indebted
households the rate of household debt is
super important to understanding how
households can propel the economy
because they do fifty four seven percent
of the economy is run on the fuel of
household spending stuff so as they take
on more debt they're gonna be a little
bit more skittish about how much they
spend so far thanks largely to federal
income replacement programs like the
Serb personal bankruptcies and other
credit problems have not yet ticked up
yet I think what we're looking at
potentially is sort of what's being
termed the deferral cliff meaning that
government supports and payment
deferrals end while the economy hasn't
fully recovered or in some cases for for
personal consumers they haven't fully
recovered surd payments right now max
out at four months and mortgage
deferrals only buy a few months of
relief government supports and payment
deferrals for some of these debts are
giving Canadians to a certain degree of
false sense of security which is
actually allowing them to put off
dealing with the debts even though that
those debts may be just as bad if not
worse when this situation ends well
things get worse for consumers we'll
consider this Canada's big banks put
aside an extra 11 billion dollars in
loan loss provisions in the last quarter
alone the banks clearly believe that
some Canadians are not going to make it
through but the debt story in this the
Cova 19 recession has a unique twist
what
absolutely clear is that women have been
hit harder than men in this recession
and that's the first time ever in
history because most recessions usually
men take it on the chin first that's
women like crystal Chalmers working in
the service industry in her case
cleaning homes and it's the service
industry that's been decimated in this
so-called qi session my children have
really struggled
I myself have really struggled if
crystal is forced to move her
neighborhood will lose a leader crystal
is president of her community League
because I'm a community leader I have
heard a lot of personal stories from
people in our community and the mental
health of people has been what's really
bothering everybody and her community
will lose a good neighbor the creator of
a giving cover for someone who might be
having trouble making ends meet and
they'll lose an artist and creator
Crystal's kids are old enough to be on
their own but for many women going back
to work cannot happen until there's a
solution for looking after the kids
schools have closed daycares have closed
they may be struggling with that
financial impact and having to look for
the care for their kids during home
during that period and that means policy
makers who want to ease a looming debt
crisis have to deal with the
responsibilities and stresses women face
a big one is child care there is no
recovery without a sheet cover E but no
she cover E with our child care and we
don't have a plan for either and while
government's ponder that issue
individuals who need cash to get through
the pandemic are urged to make plans and
seek advice do it now better to do it
now when people aren't seeking help as
much rather than waiting during a period
where maybe the demand spikes and then
you're you're gonna have trouble
actually getting the help that you need
creet Banerjee is a personal finance
expert and he's with us from Toronto
great so many Canadians were carrying so
much household debt before this pandemic
now the financial stress is through the
roof do you think we're approaching a
dangerous tipping point in Canada you
know I think we were dangerously close
to a tipping point before Koated 19
really hit if you take a look at
consumer insolvency filings they were
starting to trend up towards the end of
last year
the big banks had already started to
assume people were gonna you know not
make their debt obligations so they
started to set aside more money for bad
loans and again this was before Cove in
nineteen and because of Cobie 19 things
have just gotten exponentially worse so
let's try to divide up some of the
problems would start with mortgages more
than 700,000 Canadians have applied for
mortgage deferrals
but that's only buying time they still
owe the money of course if you're not
earning how do you deal with that yeah
it's a tough situation to be in and I
think what people really need to focus
in on is getting to that budget that
they've been procrastinating about for a
long time it really comes down to what's
coming in the door and what's going out
the door at the end of the day and if
you've had these severe income
interruptions you really need to pay
attention to what those expenses are and
create a short-term emergency budget
forecast what you would cut if you had
to make those cuts in the future so that
you reduce some of the uncertainty it
may not be good news but getting a grip
on your finances is more important now
than it's ever been
so cutting back on expenses saving if
you can read if people aren't working
now and they don't qualify for emergency
benefits from the federal government can
they do anything to insulate themselves
from the financial crisis well that
would be a very dire situation to be in
if you have no income and you don't have
any access to any of the income supports
which means you'd have to look at some
extreme measures which would include
looking at all the things that you would
unfortunately have to sell in your
household and also looking to see what
kind of social assistance programs
would be available for you as well and I
know that meet a tough idea to sort of
stomach but again you know tough times
call for tough measures you know the
silver lining I guess if there is one is
that borrowing rates are so low or is
that really a silver lining yeah it's
good question I think part of the
problem is rates have been so low for so
long that that's part of the reason that
we got into these levels of indebtedness
what might be better is if interest
rates are a little bit higher because
right now if we think that things are
going to get economically worse and
there's gonna be more fallout what steps
can you know the Bank of Canada take to
try and stimulate spending we're already
at low interest rates we can't go much
lower so I don't know if it's a silver
lining and it's also been part of the
reason why we're in this level of
indebtedness in the first place